the host of the coverage yesterday on
NBC Sports hey Mike how are you today
hello pal how you doing I'm doing great
did you get overtime yesterday no we did
not we did not get the extra 20 minutes
for running into the hockey oh it's very
disappointing okay now when the race
ends give me what the game plan is
supposed to be on NBC I'm assuming
you're supposed to be off the air at the
top of the hour 7:15 okay so the race
ends couple of interviews a little bit
of break some analysis break come back
full field winner's circle and then we
come back one more time throw it right
to hockey of the game starts so we were
we were dancing a little bit there when
did you first realize that something was
wrong we received your race ends talk
about the horse for a few seconds Donna
Brothers does a great job on horseback
gets to the outrider and the winning
jockey and the horse talks to the jockey
she usually throws it to either a
trainer and owner interview we get that
and as that's going on just as that's
going on a very very end
Rob Highland our producer said hang on a
second to me and then I was listening to
him as we started talking when the throw
came back to me I was looking at the
board and Rob told me at the time it
popped up on the board the word
objection which is part of the story
because objection means one of the
jockeys said hey something's wrong as
opposed to an inquiry where the stewards
would have thrown the flag and say hey
we thought we saw something we need to
go watch the video so hold all tickets
and don't cache them and don't rip them
up either what was the rule that was
broken essentially the horse impeded the
path of the other horses by star IV what
I've used for people who don't follow
all that often I don't pretend to be an
expert but I sit next to him on TV so if
it's a five lane highway of traffic and
the 7 horse maximum security was in the
left lane he just slammed on over to the
middle lane and interfered the progress
of the others in the way and sometimes
that happens and there's a
luckily there was contact but no crash
and that's where the problem is the
safety of the other horses and the
jockeys were put in danger because that
horse had that sharp move coming around
the turn for whatever reason that was
the problem
did your analyst agree that was was it a
consensus that this was the right call
well I'm gonna answer in in the longer
forum to help understand this why did it
take 20 minutes Jerry Bailey Randy Moss
who have been doing this for a long time
and are phenomenal at this they at first
said I don't see much there because we
were just looking at the 7 and then the
20 the horse that won so go back to that
analogy of the five lanes yeah on the
highway the 20 is like in the fourth
Lane so the 20 doesn't get bumped or
touched at all just jostle de hare and
his path continues on so the 7 did an
impact of 20 so we were looking at that
at first and then go wait a minute now
we see as you watch more angles of it we
see how it really caused a big problem
for the rest of the field so you
understand why the stewards kept looking
over and over and over and the more you
look the more you realized this was
really a problem with what happened I'm
just curious my given the track
conditions if that's factored in to what
happened on that turn people talked
about all the time without get really
super technical here on a sloppier track
it's a little bit tougher just like it
would be a little bit tougher for us to
so walk and run if it's all wet compared
to dry but most of the horses usually
handle this case fine the horse change
leads which means you're less closed in
this case is coming down first the
horses always change leads when they are
making a turn this happened a little bit
earlier than it should have with this
horse and allowed it in part two dressed
a little bit so that's why some are
pointing to the jockey could have
handled the situation a little bit
better small inside baseball stuff but
all contributing to it and does the
track addition make it tougher yeah a
little bit I'm curious if anybody asks
Gary West the owner of maximum security
if this had been reversed how would he
feel about that that he won the Derby on
a technical technicality yeah very good
question he was on The Today Show this
morning with
Savannah Guthrie Craig Melvin and when
they asked him directly hey here's the
video you saw the video does your horse
it peed the path of the others he kind
of hemmed it hard which means yeah he
did you know he wasn't going to come out
and say it
and then he spun it around and got very
anti Churchill Downs and said look here
you have 19 or 20 horses in this case in
the Derby it's the most horses in any
single race in the country all year
he called Churchill Downs greedy and
went after them for lack of transparency
in the state of Kentucky which by the
way was it a good idea if you're
planning on appealing to these people
these people so you come on the Today
Show and you trash him I know you're
upset but that is not a smart move
talking to Mike Tirico NBC Sports host
and he was on the Kentucky Derby
assignment last time you witnessed such
a huge reversal of fortune in sports hmm
Hail Mary with the animal and the
Packers that that game I was thinking as
we left something what are the three
that's the third time that I've been a
part of a no not it there are always
great endings in sports but truly
bizarre like you never saw that coming a
one for me was John Van de Velde in 99
when all he needed was a six a made a
seven went into a three-way playoff and
lost the open and then 2012 during a
Monday night game when the sale Mary
happens with the replacement officials
the last game for the replacement
officials but that was the greatest the
greatest labor negotiation stir of all
time 48 hours later hey we found common
ground the officials are back and then
and then they're so just you you come to
a game and you expect it's going to end
a certain way and you come to this event
and it it hasn't finished it was over
and we were about crowning these guys
and the owner was talking to a trainer
who saw all the emotion of it and
everything else and then all of a sudden
it's like they flip the lights on the
bars hey wait wait a minute wait a
minute the parties got to stop we got it
we got to talk about what's going on
here and then we sat around for 20
minutes and waited and what people don't
understand is when Mike is talking on TV
somebody is talking to him in his ear
and that it's one of the hardest things
you'll ever do because sometimes you
don't even know what words you're saying
because you're listening to somebody say
hey Mike you got to go here and we got
video of the steward over here looking
at this then we're going to go we got
sound over here Randy Moss is gonna have
something just like all of this is in
his head I'm assuming that you're
getting your update from from your
producer yeah Rob Highland who I
mentioned before who's with me on early
football and football night a bunch of
other stuff in Rob's Rob's awesome and
he was talking to us as much as he could
because they're trying to pass along
information from the stewards and what
do they hear there and it may be damned
if there was a disappointing part of
this on the TV and obviously we're going
to get to the hockey game as quick as we
can so we do all of our business and
then we're gonna record something for
between periods of the hockey game or
4.com or for nightly news or what or
Today Show whatever we were getting
ready to interview barber board news the
woman who came out and gave the
statement and then they said well now
they're not going to do an interview and
then they came out an hour later and
gave a statement yeah and didn't take
any questions now yeah right now you say
well wait a minute the NFL al River on
isn't hopping down there and doing a
press conference after a controversial
call okay they're not exactly the same
but essentially those are their jobs
right yeah well here's the difference
there is legal sports betting in horse
racing for years and that's the backbone
of this industry it funds the industry
the live gate the people who bet the
money and with the favorite involved I
think those people deserved an answer
more than the agreed Saints fans who are
watching a game they're disappointed
so it just opened up a whole nother
Pandora's box of when do you have to
answer to your constituents because
there's money involved in the betting
line is a Tom Brady the official host of
the Kentucky German Brady Aaron Rodgers
like we had a whole line us up we had a
Pro Bowl breaking out there with
Belichick was there Sean McVeigh was
there les Snead was there for the Rams
Brady had Garoppolo there he had jacobi
percent
those backups obviously receivers von
Miller was working for us I really do
think we could have had the greatest
eleven or seven on seventh flag football
game on the infield between races
well then Rodgers is gonna be on one
team and Brady's on the other right
no they're absolutely automatic
quarterback for each side and then we
and then we go from there if the Derby
scene is it's just so it is so different
it attracts so many people who you don't
expect this you know I mean I why this
is true storied and I've told this on
the air I'm sitting in our trailer and
you know for the folks who don't know
when we go to these events
there are trailers that it gets set up
next to the big TV trucks that's what we
work out of almost as a makeshift office
I'm there going through my scripts on
Saturday morning von Miller comes up
there's a lot to be there for a couple
of days he walked into this little couch
area where guys sit and watch the show
and we all sit and I hear hey Vaughn
yeah Dale jr. nice to me lean back my
tears we live
I just think I saw a Super Bowl MVP and
one of the most popular drivers ever in
NASCAR introduced themselves to each
other I probably had I go you guys never
met but no no hey great to meet you I'm
a big fan oh I'm a big fan of yours
that's the Derby that happens like at no
other big sporting event it's just a
really cool fun see as I've told people
before if you have the ability to and
you haven't you should at least once get
to the Derby it's really cool
Paulie came up with an idea first hour
the do-over and you have these two these
two horses they race and you do it at
Churchill well we can't they probably
won't get back in church he'll down Gary
West is not bringing maximum security
there but how about five million dollars
winner-take-all and national TV would
you host it absolutely I think we pass
around the head to the Danette they all
chip in and we put the money up and
let's do it
why not now we're not going to see the
Preakness no no's West said he's and
that's not uncommon usually if you don't
win the Derby and you don't feel like
you guys saw the Preakness you may hold
your horse to the Belmont
so perhaps we'll see it in the Belmont
or someplace else during the summer the
one thing that we haven't really talked
much about because the contrary
is this horse country-houses 65 to 1
shot who got very little attention
during the week ok he didn't beat
maximum security
he beat everybody else he's a pretty
good horse how good is he I guess we'll
find out at the Preakness but that's
like down the line for next week but
maybe we will see them in some race
somewhere that would be good for the
sport the sport could use something good
happening here down the line so that
would be that would at least garner
interest was yesterday what was the
Derby finished good for this morning
Saturday it was good for attention I
don't know if it was good for the sport
the right thing happened in the long run
because it brought to light that there
are safety and safety concerns that have
to factor into the results but the
publicity was otherwise negative if
people open up the door and look
sometimes they're going to see more bad
into sports sometimes they'll see the
people in the sport who by and large the
ones I've met are pretty good so I don't
necessarily think it was a home run of
great publicity for the sport but it got
a lot of people talking about it I might
get the feeling that there'll be a lot
of people who were interested in the
Preakness just because of what happened
I don't know if many people did what I
did once once the horse across the
finish line wired a wire and then there
was a interview with the jockey and then
all of a sudden I went to do something
else in the house and I came back 10
minutes later and I go wait why is the
second-place finish owner celebrating
exactly and then like I was like oh my
god so I missed it in real time I came
back and then all of a sudden I realized
I had to wait 12 more minutes to find
out who won the Kentucky Derby I
wouldn't be surprised if people did that
I wouldn't be surprised I was Michael at
some point that as you know things go
viral something happens people start
texting their friends that people were
coming in trying to figure out what was
happening you come into the middle of
that good good luck figuring it out the
ratings are always interesting Dan the
ratings go up obviously as you get
closer to an event that always happens a
big sporting events but from 16 to 65 we
had three four five million viewers at
least in that stretch so you know the
audience is constantly building and once
they came for this and they saw this
whole mess
play out and I'm sure a whole bunch of
them hung around to watch what was going
on so fascinating stuff I've never I've
never seen playbook it's never happened
in the history of the Derby 145 years so
glad we got to see it with our own eyes
good to visit with you Mike great stuff
on Saturday and talk to you soon anytime
you know we love you pal we we're on
your corner and we think the world of
you so that's about the best we had a
lot of good radio hits to do in the
future years so keep going buddy
Thank You bud that's Mike Tirico NBC
host and on the call with the Kentucky
Derby for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at